We saw earlier, that if we multiply a complex number by its conjugate, the
middle terms cancel out and so we end up with a real number. This is exactly
what we're looking for in this situation, to make our denominator what we want
it to be. Since we don't want to change the value of this fraction that we had
initially, we need to multiply by 1 in the form of the conjugate over itself.
Now, we just need to multiply the numerators of these fractions and their
denominators. At first start of multiplying out, gives us a fraction that I
think is pretty clear we can reduce a little bit more. So, let's keep
simplifying. Our final answer is negative 7 plus 22i all over 13. I think this
definitely looks a lot more manageable than what we started out with. Awesome
job.